is it permissible for an Imam of a
mosque to collect the
zakat and distribute it to those who are
entitled to
it even if that is a while later does it
increase
if there is inflation it's very
interesting
question as far as an Imam collecting
Zak as I mentioned earlier there are
various hadiths mentioning that someone
can collect Z it's mentioned in s bukari
volume number three in the book of
representations Hadith number 2311 that
Abu with him he says that the messenger
of Allah mammad Ali wasallam he had
appointed him to keep the Zak he was
appointed as one of the collectors and
there other Hadith in
of which says that when a person asked
that when did Omar him when did he used
to give his Zak
so the person replies that after the
collectors had finished that means they
were collectors at the time of the
Prophet so someone collecting on behalf
of anyone else it's permitted but you
should see to the person collecting is
honest you know like IM of MK
alhamdulillah no problem an organization
it can be given regarding the question
that can it be given later that means
the person who collects it can he give
it later no the right ruling is the
person who collects he can collect a few
days earlier that's no problem but it
should reach the recipient
before the Eid Salah of is over that's
very important and it should reach in
the form of food you can give money to
The Collector if you don't have food or
you can give food directly but the
person collecting should see to it that
if you give money it should buy the
amount of food required for the
stipulated share of Z and you should see
to it it reaches the recipient before
the recipient goes for E Salah is the
best that's the best or on the Eve one
day earlier
as far as inflation is concerned should
the zakat F increase see since zakat f
is not in currency
note it's in form of food so if
inflation is there the cost for you to
buy the food will increase but one will
remain
onea so what onea could purchase maybe
20 100 years back if it may be costing
maybe a couple of pounds or a few rupees
today it may have increased but One S of
rice remains one of rice one of Bali one
of dat so that's the reason it is hikma
of Allah subhana wa taala and his
messenger they gave it in kind not in
cash if Z was in cash then the problem
inflation have come same thing with
zakat it's the form of gold if you have
Surplus more than 85 gr of gold it
doesn't say Surplus more than1 pound or
,000 or $100 $1,000 100 rupees or th000
rupees it's in form of kind so if
inflation is there the cost for buying
that kind increases but the amount
Remains the Same so inflation also it
will be one s of date or reisin or rise
Etc okay does have the answer